cowering in terrors gunshots ring out in
quick succession this shopping mall is
under siege police response teams arrive
quickly to lockdown the site the gunman
identified by local media his 21
year-old Patrick Cru seus this CCTV
image captures the moment he walks into
the mall armed with an automatic rifle
prepared to cause mass casualties
he starts puppies going for that semi
trigger finger he's going going going
it's Saturday morning and the mall is
packed with families mothers with young
children buying their back-to-school
supplies as the summer holidays come to
an end but as the gunshots echo through
the mall panic spreads as people begin
to realize exactly what is happening
heavily armed police leads some of the
people to safety
[Music]
and then he was like shots I said yes
people were running inside saying there
was a shooter we took off towards the
back of the store where the stock room
was we were pushing people out the way
and telling them to go
I talked to another guy that said he saw
somebody shot in the head in another
name as police SWAT teams descend on
them all that terror and confusion
separates families and loved ones do you
want a coffee have seven kids
twenty-something grandchildren and I
don't know how many great waiting where
my mom is
so my name's little too mouse key and
we're looking for my brother-in-law I'm
very on trouble we've been waiting at
the hospitals both hospitals are they
been dropping him off at you know the
unification Center and saw it we got
worried we're just trying to put the
word out there if anybody's hard for me
the gunman has been arrested by the
police FBI investigators are now
examining a 2300 word document allegedly
shared online by Cruces it's full of
hatred for immigrants and big business
he attacks politicians both Democrats
and Republicans and says he held these
views before President Trump came to
power right now we have a manifesto from
this individual that indicates to some
degree as a nexus to potential hate
crime they didn't mean to step on FBI
stoles on that but we are taking this
down the road of simply a murder
investigation with numerous casualties
and as I said the state of Texas will be
the lead prosecuting agency in this as
Texas reeled from this carnage hours
away further north more blood was spilt
on American streets
dude what the this time drinkers in a
bar in Dayton Ohio
no warning just a burst of gunfire and
nine people shot dead more would have
died but for a passing patrol car
responding quickly identifying the
gunman and shooting him dead
if Dayton police had not gotten to the
shooter in under a minute and think of
that 30 26 injured nine dead hundreds of
people in the organ district could be
dead today the gunman has not been
identified and FBI investigators are yet
to establish a motive even in a country
hardened to gun crime this has been the
bloodiest of weeks three mass shootings
were the last two just hours apart
unlikely though to make Americans
finally put down their guns
Ashish Joshi sky news